[Musique]
lambert est un opposant de régime syrien
mais moins je n'étais pas d'accord avec
lui je veux dire même après avoir fermé
le club d'échecs en à des rats dans ma
ville et mon péché de continuer ma
passion j'aimais quand même le régime
syrien
même si je détestais arriver tôt à
l'école le matin depuis que je suis tout
petit nous mettrons rang et répétait le
parti répétait le slogan du parti unique
albas en syrie ouattara qui a dans le
froid en plus à mes jeux mais quand même
le régime syrien même si aussi je
détestais cette matière qu'on appelle
études civique en syrie et qui consiste
à nous apprendre par coeur les étaux
apportée par la famille gouvernants la
série depuis vraiment qu'on est tout
petit mais quand même j'aime bien cette
famille mais c'est parce qu ils nous
envoyaient des bus à l'école pour n'aura
mené à des manifestations pour qu'on
crie qu'on chante mais tout ce qu'on
veut bon tout ce qu'on veut c'est est
plutôt on t'adore notre cher président
au fait à ce moment là j'avais 10 ans je
suis né à dera ma ville natale ainsi que
la ville natale de la révolution
syrienne et j'aimerais vous parler de
quelques événements que j'ai vécu que
j'ai vu avec mes propres yeux et non pas
à travers la télé les enfants savez vous
que tout ce basculement en syrie est
causée par des enfants oui oui des
enfants de l'âge de 10 à 14 ans des
enfants de dera c'était en février 2011
que des enfants écrit sur le mur de leur
école c'est au tour des enfants qui on
regardait la télé avec leurs parents qui
ont vu ce qui se passait en egypte et en
tunisie
vous savez les enfants ils aiment bien
imiter nous léguant et leur punissant
était de les arrêter par les polices et
de l'es2 les ont prisonniers et de les
torturer et qu'un judy torture et s'est
enlevé leur angle c'est les électrisés
les parents de ces enfants sont allés
voir le chef des polices ils demandaient
leur enfant est la réponse du chef des
polices avait été clair et net et je le
transmets mon parement oubliez vos
enfants et allait en faire d'autres
et si vous ne savez pas en faire amenez
vos femmes et on le fera à votre place
voici monsieur dame la raison directe
cumulait avec beaucoup d'autres raisons
dans le passé pourquoi les habitants de
berra se sont manifestés le 18 mars 2011
déclenchant la révolution syrienne
ce jour-là 18 mars 2011 c'était un
vendredi
c'était le week end en série c'est le
week end c'est donc j'ai fait ma grasse
matinée je me suis réveillé j'étais en
train de faire mes devoirs et j'entends
des hélicoptères par la fenêtre
c'est anormal je regarde ils sont tout
près je cours vers la mer je vous
demande qu'est ce qui se passe et me dis
que ton père vient de partir à une
manifestation qui a lieu à dans une
place qui s'appelle zakat leur mari donc
on descend chez ma grand'mère on ouvre
la télé mais rien sur les nouvelles en
un temps et en attend puis mon cousin
revient de la manifestation il nous
explique que les manifestants a demandé
la libération de ses enfants mais aussi
la libération des prisonniers politiques
et la chute du maire de bérat la réponse
était les électeurs que j'ai vu en
intérêts dans le stade de dar des
gendarmes habillés en noir qui sont
apparemment spécialisés pour ce genre de
situation ont descendu ont couru des
kilomètres jusqu'au lieu de la
manifestation est la première chose
qu'ils font c'est ouvrir le feu le
premier jour deux morts sont tombés et
quatre blessés je sais de deux morts
c'est pas un nombre choquant aujourd'hui
mais croyez moi cette époque c'est un
nombre très très choquant pour des rats
c'était en fait beaucoup beaucoup plus
qu'un nombre c'étaient des enfants qui
ont perdu leur père des enfants qui ont
passé toute la nuit un pleurait c'était
femmes qui ont perdu leurs maris et
pourquoi le lendemain tout le monde
voulait se manifester contre cette
violence mais chacun avait peur d'être
le seul à cause de cette violence
finalement les manifestants étaient dix
fois nombreux et plus il y avait du sang
juste les gens étaient nombreux dans les
rues quarante jours plus tard vera était
assiégée par l'armée série l'armé de
notre pays
on avait plus du lait plus du pain et
pourquoi parce on ne se manifestait
pacifiquement les les habitants des
villages entourant des rats ont décidé
de ramener du lait du pain de marcher
des kilomètres jusqu'aux des rats
marcher à pied jusqu'à des rats et tout
en portant des branches d'olivier pour
signaler que leurs actes et pacifique
à l'arrivée l'armée très gentil les
centres et les manifestants une fois
qu'ils sont au centre de vera l'armée
ouvre le feu je peux vraiment affirmer
que c'est le pire jour de ma vie les
gens couraient les gens tombaient autour
de nous et puis des gens marchaient sur
ces gens qui s'empare terres qui sont en
train de mourir
je veux dire je ne peux pas vraiment
vous décrire la scène avec moi
d'ailleurs le quartier le plus proche de
ce lieu était le quartier à majorité
chrétienne à des rats et les chrétiens
ont ouvert leurs portes très grande pour
les blessés et d'ailleurs je connais une
femme amie de ma mère qui est
aujourd'hui à paris qui habitait ce jour
là dans ce quartier et qui a accueilli
des blessés
le lendemain de ce jour horrible je suis
passé par cette rue et tout ce que je
voyais c'était les chaussures de ces
gens qui essayaient de fuir
c'était du lait du pain tout mélangé
avec du sang mais vous savez ce qui est
peut-être pire que mourir de cette façon
c'est c'est d'après mon cousin hamza
être dans une petite prison voir les
gens victoire mourir lentement et
entendre les cris d'autres gens tout en
sachant que tu est le suivant mon cousin
hamza était un étudiant en droit à damas
à la faculté de damas il n'a jamais
porté dame n'a jamais connu la un jour
les poulies ska la porte de cheikh hamza
et le prennent sous les yeux de sa mère
en bref la méthode de torture était de
le pendre tout en laissant les
extrémités du ses pieds touchaient une
chaise il était tout nu et électrisée
dans toutes les parties de son corps
voici une raison pourquoi
hamza est aujourd'hui un réfugié
heureusement il a pu résister et
malheureusement contrairement à beaucoup
d'autres gens qui étaient avec lui et
c'est pourquoi il est devenu un réfugié
quant à moi plusieurs plusieurs raisons
aussi en fait que je suis devenu un
réfugié que j'ai quitté mon pays dont
l'une d'entre elles c'est ce jour là
quand j'étais avec ma mère ma grande
mère ma tante et mon petit frère dans la
voiture une période de police nous
arrêtent prennent les cartes d'identité
pour les vérifier l'habituel puis
reviennent et prennent ma mère
on était choqués on ne savait pas quoi
faire je je me suis tourné vers mon
petit frère qui avait 10 ans à l'époque
il était tout silence y ait des larmes
coulaient de ses yeux mais a tenté ma
grand'mère essaye de nous calmer mais
commence elle aussi à pleurer ils sont
partis avec ma mère on les a suivis avec
la voiture pour quelques centaines de
mètres il a ils sont entrés au stade de
dar saad verra là où on entendait qu'ils
exécutaient les gens
vraiment la seule pensée que j'avais
dans la tête ou la seule question était
est ce que ma mère est vivante à ce
moment là est-ce que je vais la revoir
je ne voulais croire que cela bien sûr
mais à des moments je n'imaginais que le
contraire heureusement il lui a juste
posé des questions sur mon père parce
que mon père était activistes dès le
premier jour il parlait aux chaînes
internationaux pour raconter ce qui se
passait à des rapports transmettre
l'image parce que le régime syrien
interdisait aux médias internationaux
rentrés en ciel et ma mère est sortie et
après plusieurs menaces après que mon
père soit parti de la série on a décidé
et on a été obligé de quitter la série
je me rappelle ce jour là j'étais à
l'aise chez moi chez mes grands-parents
pour pas à dire au revoir à tout le
monde en fait j'ai appris le jour même
que cette nuit je vais quitter mon pays
j'arrive et je vais oublier mon parfum
chez moi je demande à ma mère de rendre
d'aller chez moi avant d'aller à la
frontière pour chercher mon parfum et la
matante se moque de moi et me dit tu vas
à paris tu va mener un parfum avec toi
mais vu les prix des parfums à paris
elle me doit un parfum absolument un je
vous rappelle aussi comment mon ami omar
priait ma mère que je reste chez lui
c'était mon ami mon meilleur ami la
voiture est arrivée je suis sorti j'ai
avancé vers la voiture et plusieurs
avancées je vais ce sentiment je je
réalisais que en fait demain je serai
pas en syrie que j'aurais même pas le
droit de rentrer dans mon propre pays de
revoir mes proches mes amis aller dans
les endroits où où j'ai grandi je suis
entré dans la voiture
j'étais un dernier regard sur ma
grand-mère et ses larmes ont touché ce
qu'il ya de plus profond en moi ma mère
ma grande mère que je ne les ai jamais
vus depuis et que je ne la verrai jamais
croyez moi ce n'était pas mon choix de
quitter mon pays c'était pas mon choix
de choisir ne plus rentrer dans man dans
en séries et c'était vraiment pas mon
choix de ne plus voir ma grand'mère
malgré tout cela j'ai traversé la
frontière et nous avons pris l'avion à
amman pour rejoindre mon père à paris tu
pris l'avion avec des sentiments divisée
entre la syrie mes proches mes amis et
la nouvelle vie qui m'attend en france
et mon père aussi
les deux premiers mois je les ai passées
à faire des papiers donc je n'étais pas
encore à l'école je ne parlais pas un
mot de français
je fais rêver en janvier 2012 et et je
me rappelle un jour j'étais allé jouer
au foot et j'ai commencé à parler une
fille de mon âge et je vais parler en
anglais ne comprenais pas bien l'anglais
après une longue discussion et il me
pose des questions donc j'essaie de lui
expliquer pourquoi j'ai quitté la série
tout simplement je me rappelle toujours
de ce moment comment il a ouvert ses
yeux grands il m'a regardé et m'a dit yu
phase juste un chouïa je ne sais pas
quand elle est arrivée à cette
conclusion
plus tard j'ai entendu que c'est ce
qu'on appelle un malentendu plus tard
j'ai commencé à apprendre le français et
je dois dire que j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance parce que je suis venu en france
et parce que je suis venu en avion voir
la mairie c'est en montant
c'est très joli mais quand je regarde
loin ça me fait très peur
vraiment j'adore la france pour tout ce
qu'elle m'a offert la chance la
protection l'éducation et surtout
j'adore les gens que j'ai rencontrés en
france
ces gens qui m'ont toujours aidé et qui
était toujours souriant pour lesquelles
j'étais haitham et non pas un migrant
patrick basile et catherine cette
famille que méme on ne peut jamais les
remercie assez font partie de ces gens
là j'ai très nombreux gens cette famille
m'a accueilli pendant l'été 2012 pour
m'aider à apprendre le français mais ils
ont fait beaucoup plus que mme apprendre
le français
ils m'ont fait découvrir la vie
française la culture française avec eux
j'ai vécu des moments mais inoubliable
si avec eux ils m'ont pas ce ils ne
m'ont pas seulement a pris le moins
optimiste
ils m'ont fait croire en ce moment c'est
avec cette famille que j'ai découvert le
lait fromages français dont je
n'apprécie pas trop l'odeur c'est avec
basile et ses amis que j'ai sympathisé
pour la première fois avec des jeunes
français de mona et qui m'ont appris
beaucoup de mots dont je n'ai pas le
droit de dire la majorité de ses mains
usées
[Musique]
vraiment merci bazine merci patrick
merci catherine vous serez toujours
l'exemple que je suivrai dans ma vie
puis j'ai continué mes études j'étais au
lycée d'abord j'ai obtenu mon bac et
maintenant je suis en deuxième année à
l'université je fais des mathématiques
je suis fais le avec nicolas naquit au
parc
nous avons créé la bande dessinée dont
le but est de vous parler comme je vous
je vous parle aujourd'hui la même
manière j'espère qu'un jour qu'on a et
sauve les gens qui sont en train de
mourir en syrie j'espère que quand jour
je puisse avoir le choix de rentrer dans
mon propre pays
j'espère qu'on puisse y fonder un pays
qu'on puisse fonder une éducation
j'espère que les pays candidats droits
d'homme agissent qu'ils interviennent et
j'espère surtout de vous de ce tous ceux
qui m'écoutent
n'oubliez s'il vous parle jamais si vous
s'il vous plaît jamais quand vous pensez
à la une solution ou quel que soit quand
vous pensez à la syrie la racine du
problème comment tout a commencé
n'oubliez pas ce que je vous ai raconté
raconter parce qu'on a toujours tendance
à oublier la racine du problème comment
tout a commencé
merci la france pour tout ce que tu m'as
offert merci pour tout le monde
j'espère que la france ouvre à ses bras
encore plus pour les gens ont besoin de
protection d'éducation comme com - comme
la france se faisait dans le passé comme
le fait l'allemagne aujourd'hui et
surtout merci à vous les français pour
ce bon accueil et pour tous ces sourires
[Applaudissements]